katie is crying and christian is taking
up the church and derrick path is the
respectful king of our time look if this
is what makes you happy you're making
the right decision this is your bachelor
in paradise episode six recap grab your
glasses it's time for roses and rosy did
you hear that
I threw the blanket with such fervor the
tapes that are lighting well that should
be happening because this episode shed
some light bachelor nation
oh what a moments everybody I will take
you anyway you come any choice you make
you know I got your back we had a
landmark night for the bachelor
franchise our first same-sex kiss on
screen ever in this franchise
we witnessed love we witness respect we
witnessed tears and we're here to talk
about it all I don't have rose aid today
I have Chardonnay with some fabulous
glacier ice cubes it was a big episode
you know so I know I had to really like
go to my home base to make sure I was
good but I am wearing a rosy colored
shirt let's get to it we're gonna get to
it by saying poor Derek I am feeling
every feeling I can
you guys Derick is selfless Derick is
crying I wish it wasn't hard demi
Dericks love interest is talking to
Chris Harrison and telling him that she
still has feelings for this woman she
was dating before she left for the show
and I can't imagine not having her in my
life she still seemed so conflicted but
I think Chris's question was key can you
imagine not having Derrick in your life
maybe she can't live without this woman
he said could you live without Derrick
the answer felt clear didn't I mean we
know that Demi and Derrick are favorite
double D are also deeper done this girl
is literally atrocious
real quick though drink every time
someone turns on Christina Shulman she's
awful like this girl is literally
atrocious yeah because I'm awesome he's
manipulated Christina's like the
mosquitos here she's just
the life ed of everyone now the girls
are heating on her look I want my friend
to find love here in paradise
do you want him to find laughs yeah and
this new gal Caitlyn goes and Seifer
confronts her and I didn't understand it
I need to see for communication I just
wasn't very impressed with Caitlyn's
points I also thought that she's super
contradicted herself
Caitlyn came at christina over the Blake
thing you know Caitlyn's arguing there
Christina's just trying to get a
friendship Rose is there anybody you're
interested in thank yo it's a friendship
rose and I've told you that but
Christina's totally owning that she's
just trying to get a friendship rose
from Blake she had just given him a
friendship rose and I don't hold this
against Christina do you a big part of
paradise is that new people come in all
the time so christina is thinking well I
want to stay in Paradise because a new
person might come in and they could be
the right person for me I don't falter
for that who did you side with here
Caitlyn or Christina Caitlyn said some
pretty mean words about Christina
Christina didn't really say anything
like that about Caitlyn oh you're
you're impossible and then Kaitlyn
pulled this and told Christina women
should always respect women
you should respect women and like women
should always respect women
girl a hot second ago you said she was a
bug you needed to squish and then
speaking of women a new one is here Jen
Saviano you will remember that she and
Nick vile fell for each other in
paradise in walks Jen Saviano who in my
opinion is one of the most beautiful
girls in all of bachelor nation if not
the entire planet Earth we haven't seen
her in a minute Jen looks great I'm
interested that she's here and then I've
learned why these producers must have
done some real taking Jen Saviano is
here because she's beautiful yes because
she wants to find love yes but I'm gonna
go ahead and guess she's also here
because she had Blake hung out well
Blake was ghosting me he was hanging out
with her oh my god I wrote down I want
to throw up Jen 7'o is not a stagecoach
she did not hook up but she's gorgeous
she really is this episode had some
people nearly puking and I included
myself in that there were some things
that I wanted to throw up over because
I've lost emotions I can't laugh about
it the stagecoach thing anymore I can't
cry about the Blake at stagecoach thing
anymore I just have to vomit I gotta get
it out I gotta get it out of me I can't
take it you know but Jen's feeling
things out she talks to Dean Dean 10
bucks on James Dean
do you wanna chat oh yeah and oh my god
cheers to Dean for this cute moment with
Kaelyn hey can I talk to you for a
second I'm just kidding come on I'm not
going on a date with no one Dan I love
you and your mustaches joint solidarity
[Music]
[Applause]
Katie kind of made a mistake with Chris
things are going well with them but
Katie also told him you know the new
girl comes in feel free to date her I
just think old Christine do whatever I
was like hey go out with whatever girls
you want and drink every time Katie says
that that was a self-defense mechanism
I'm afraid of getting hurt a little bit
just to protect myself I was putting up
a wall to protect myself
Jennifer judge myself drink every time
Katie says she self sabotages those
sabotages just to protect myself
so stop tossing a drink every time Katie
cries and I know I deserve it all
I'm crying on the beach
please drink responsibly like I want
this to bring more clarity I've made a
decision we have to change we must grow
we need to evolve and it is necessary
that we accept the word clarity yours
bring you more clarity yes
my body's rejecting this I know but we
have to they're saying it so much I
think it's the new journey I think it's
the new amazing I think it's the new
open vulnerable honest clarity is here
to stay I drink every time someone's in
clarity yours bringing more clarity yes
so I could get some clarity I don't know
if there's a new producer who's joined
the crew and it has incorporated the
word clarity I don't know but it's not
going anywhere
[Music]
okay I've evolved and they welcome it so
Chris is feeling quite shook by Katy
telling him update somebody else I got
your free man and Jen asks him on the
date and he says okay and they say they
hope it's about date me too but then the
boat date takes a turn to puke yeah it's
rough waters you know and Chris nearly
vomits the theme of this episode is
purging there are sail boats and there
are barf boats and this is the latter
and a barf boat feels right for this
season of paradise but Chris and Jen
push through you know and they're
hanging or they're hot tubbing and
they're kissing and katie is reminiscing
I know Chris really likes me and
regretting I just and how are you guys
feeling I almost wanted Katie to just go
jump in the hot tub and be like I like
you but she didn't instead she just
talked through everything with everyone
else and then Nicole is singing to clay
your biceps are so yummy
[Music]
won't you come in be my honey okay okay
cheering from the sidelines you take
away my frown line but um she's a
beautiful voice I just the lyrics
weren't there for me okay moving on
because we must we must purge we get a
moment where Blake is lamenting that
America hasn't seen his fun sighs oh my
god America's gonna see my funny side
like I beg to differ we know we've seen
and we've heard about all the fun you
have to drink for all the couples in the
pool Dean and Galen Hannah and Dylan pa
heart everyone is all in damn can I
steal you for a second yeah but now
things are about to get serious and
important
Chris Harrison is here and he is brought
Christian for Demi
yes Demi's gal Christian is here and
Demi cries upon a sight of her it's a
really beautiful moment they reach for
each other they kiss each other it's
beautiful and real fast
Demi chooses Christian like the seconds
and I saw you like I knew exactly
I guess here it is oil then
and I want to be with you she obviously
has a bigger history with Christian and
she did with Derek
she says that seeing Christian was kind
of the final piece of the puzzle it made
her realize that the feelings for
Christian were where she wanted to be
I'm glad that you're moving towards what
makes you happier anymore like that
sucks to know it's not me I play
I don't get to decide that and now we
must raise our glass to Derrick path
that was a slant rhyme but it was worth
it because Derrick path is worth it you
guys someone date
Derrick we have talked about respectful
Kings Tyler see Dylan B and now Derrick
P this man the way that he handled being
broken up with by Demi learning that the
new person dummy was gonna be with was
here on the beach that he was gonna have
to watch all that the level of
perspective the level of grace Derrick
is a touch somebody reach out and grab
him okay he's great well vlogging from
my home welcome
you guys should Derrick be the bachelor
he's got a lot of people on the train
for this now they are supporting it he
was so wonderful with Demi he's been
engaged before he's ready for love let
me know in the comments below and we
have exclusive reporting on the
possibility update the mmm Jamie's blood
Demi breaks up with Derek and tells him
Christian is gonna be staying here on
the beach and Derek it's kind of like
yikes because like I wanted to be happy
and Derek actually wants to talk to
Christian I would love to have a
conversation with her early before the
rest of this
oh my god are you kidding me I mean the
adult in here is wild ABCD always be
catching Derek somebody do it okay Timmy
and Christian please use this to
rekindle your flame Demi and Christian
go on a date and they talk things
through and you know Christian like is a
cast member now she's here because she's
getting a day rate sure I did an
interview with Rob Mills who is an
executive EC shameless plug and he
pointed out this is not the first time
that someone who wasn't a franchise alum
was brought into paradise that Ashley I
can I'd his sister was brought into
paradise so this is not a first but a
woman and a woman dating each other on
paradise is a first and I love seeing
their date and I want to connect here
and I might never want to commit to
someone like this before
Wow my apartment is so messy I'm a woman
on the go you know and I want to speak
about two other women a little bit more
Demi and Christian because a lot of
people are still comparing Demi to Jed
Wyatt saying that she schemed in having
a relationship before coming on to the
show I'm gonna interview dummy and I'm
gonna ask her about this because I want
to hear her address the allegations but
I will also say that I am just so happy
to see a same-sex relationship on the
show to see it embraced to see the two
of them get a date together kiss that I
just want to revel in that a little bit
you know so we will investigate more
what an episode it was of course let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
I am on cameo if you want a personal
message for me yo and I love you all so
much thank you thank you thank you for
watching bye look at your socks
mhm you know who else is great this guy
that's all
we're just loving on great men